on constate aujourd'hui que le fait que
les jeunes sont exclus du rsa donc les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans donc là en la
proposition qui a été faite par monsieur
la taille était éventuellement de
repartir sur un revenu universel qui
avait été pensé par l'institut montaigne
par aussi dépenser plus libérale comme
thomas sky link bien chez alain fournier
ou encore de moi avons ici s'agirait
donc de si je me suis renseigné de
réunir plusieurs allocations pas de les
faire tomber
justement ou financées par nos impôts
mais plutôt de réunir des allocations
qui existe déjà
que ce soit la prime d'activité
l'allocation logement le rsa alors après
je suis sceptique évidemment parce que
la question qu'il faut se poser est en
réalité y en a trois sait quel montant
c'est quel financement
et qu'est-ce qu'on remplace et donc ces
questions elles sont essentielles et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse
donc est-ce qu'on peut exclure de but en
blanc un revenu qui nous serait proposé
non par contre il faut être bien
conscient de ce que ça implique
qu'est-ce qu'on replace est important
est effectivement comment on le finance
parce que donner une aide c'est super
mais aujourd'hui les étudiants n'ont pas
besoin seulement d'une heure ils ont
besoin d'un accompagnement
ils ont besoin d'un accompagnement dans
leur insertion professionnelle dans leur
réussite d'études et dans leurs
conditions de vie générales
au fond le revenu universel étudiants
c'est une proposition qui est
démagogique et qui à mon avis est
déconnecté des revendications des
étudiants
moi je suis opposé d'abord parce que ce
serait une nouvelle prestation
inconditionnels c'est à dire que ray pas
ça impliquerait pas de recherche
d'emploi ou de formation
contrairement aux prestations actuelles
que qui sont par exemple les allocations
chômage ou le rsa et là on comprend bien
la logique de cette prestation qui va à
l'encontre de la valeur travail parce
que le travail c'est ce qui permet à
chacun de s'émanciper de se construire
de se construire intellectuellement
d'avoir confiance en soi ou même
d'obtenir des crédits bancaires et et
moi je suis ici opposé à cette
proposition parce que personne n'est
dupe
concernant son coût comment ils vont la
financer cette proposition d'abord par
des augmentations d'impôts indirects
c'est à dire la tête
ea qui touche tout le monde y compris
les étudiants et ensuite par de la dette
et aujourd'hui on a une dette qui
s'élève à 120 % du pib
il faut bien comprendre que cette dette
c'est notre génération qui va la payer
avant de penser à un revenu universel
qui on sait tous ce sera jamais
appliquée j'aimerais quand même vous
rappeler la situation de détresse des
étudiants qui depuis presqu'un an sont
enfermés dans des logements crous de 9
mètres carrés qui sont privés d'une
association fondamental que l'université
donc depuis le début de cette crise ya
trois cent mille étudiants qui ont perdu
leur emploi
il ya un étudiant sur six qui a été
saisi de suite ya 30 % des étudiants qui
sont en dépression il ya un étudiant sur
cinq qui nourrit des pensées suicidaires
et moi j'ai une pensée pour cet étudiant
delà de la faculté de médecine de la
sorbonne qui vient de mettre fin à ses
jours
donc face à la détresse des étudiants
nous la réponse qu'on a eu de la part de
l'amnésie dalle c'est quoi c'est à
nouveau un nouveau numéro vert comme
s'il n'avait pas assez et c'est le
doublement du nombre de psychologues on
va passer d'un psychologue pour vos
trente minutes pour trente mille
étudiants un psychologue pour quinze
mille étudiants donc moi je fais passer
ce message à la mine vidal maintenant
faut arrêter de mépriser la colère des
étudiants
il faut écouter leur détresse il faut
rouvrir les universités faut rouvrir les
facs
non mais écoutez
au lieu de mettre en place ce rsa
déguisés pour les 18-25 ans à mon avis à
des mesures qui sont très simple et
moins coûteuse qui peuvent être
appliquées dès maintenant
en premier lieu la clé la création d'un
ticket restaurant étudiants qui serait
basée sur un modèle salariés c'est une
idée qui est porté par l'uni depuis
telle à plusieurs années et qui
permettrait à tous les étudiants de
bénéficier de ceux de ce ticket
restaurant d'une valeur de 6 euros 60 y
compris ceux qui habitent loin des
résidences du restaurant au crous la
deuxième propose la deuxième proposition
bardon c'est la construction de
logements étudiants
le président de la république macron
s'était engagé à la construction de 60
mille logements étudiants sur la durée
du quinquennat et je vais vous dire on
les attend encore et la troisième
proposition que je pourrais vous faire
c'est c'est d'élargir le système de
bourses pour permettre à tous les
étudiants qui méritent et qui ont perdu
leur travail notamment pour cette crise
sanitaire de bénéficier des bourses pour
vivre décemment étudier dans de bonnes
conditions à l'université moi ce que je
reproche à ce gouvernement en fait c'est
d'avoir aucun cap d'avoir aucun horizon
c'est à dire qu'on admire de
l'enseignement supérieur qui est
totalement déconnecté qui apparaît tout
les toutes les deux semaines pour pour
une déclaration devant les français où
elle paraît complètement déconnecté de
nos revendications
elle nous a quand même dit je cite ce
qui pose problème ce n'est pas le cours
dans l'envié mais l'étudiant qui prend
un café à la pause
un bonbon qui traînent sur la table donc
ça nous montre à quel point elle prend
les étudiants pour des enfants les
infantilise et honnêtement les étudiants
ne le peuvent pas apprécié ce manque de
considération
alors avant tout je vais juste si vous
permettez à vos gonds dire sur ce que
lui disait monsieur carayon précédemment
dont vous parlez du système idéal
c'était les les actions et mesures qui
sont mises en place on a des actions qui
sont mises en place telles que la
garantie jeunes qui est un dispositif
qui fonctionne mais pas pour tout le
monde
je pense qu'il est important de
mentionner également que les universités
travaillent énormément indépendamment de
des aides étatiques et que l'on à de
nombreuses missions locales qui agissent
dans dans ces mesures telles que la
garantie jeunes donc c'est la première
étape cohérent ça serait de pouvoir
mettre en place ou améliorer des
systèmes qui existent déjà et des
systèmes qu'ils ont utilisés par les
étudiants mais qui sont très peu connus
ce serait également de d'ajouter un
petit peu de cohérence dans ce système
de bourse
parce que si on considère la façon dont
sont organisés les bourses on voit qu'un
euro près parfois on peut passer d'un
cap à l'autre et sa part déneigement
mais je trouve ça absolument encore la
même façon si votre vos parents sont
auto-entrepreneurs leurs revenus ne sont
pas pris en compte
donc on accède à l'échelon boursiers qui
étaient beaucoup plus importantes et
importe le revenu fiscal de la famille
donc je pense que la première chose
avant d'envisager un système idéal c'est
d'améliorer et d'apporter de la
cohérence dans le système qui est déjà
existants